et avant de s'exprimer sur la durée du
confinement lundi emmanuel macron était
hier à marseille une visite surprise
pour rencontrer le professeur didier
raoult est allé qui préconise la
prescription de chloroquine pour les
malades atteints du coc u19 à mais dont
la position et les méthodes ne font pas
toujours l'unanimité dans la communauté
scientifique et avant à l'allocution de
lundi emmanuel macron edouard philippe
multiplie actuellement les réunions avec
les présidents de groupes parlementaires
les chefs de partis les syndicats ou
encore le patronat le dialogue a été
agitée entre des soignants et le
président macro hier à l'hôtel du
kremlin bicêtre
on ne me coûte un extrait
[Musique]
et ça paie
tél
j'entends et je ne comptais pas
je suis arrivé
[Musique]
eh bien
il
hu
il y avait tout